you were funny in an otherworldly uh
Supernatural way and it doesn't that's
the thing that I think
comes first I think it's
um having that whatever that is I don't
understand what it is but that ability
to
uh be funny and creative
and and you have such a quick mind and
your improvisational skills are just off
the hook and
your stuff is always solid gold that's
what you have and then you're using it I
think to tell this story but you know
that rule number one is uh the work oh
yeah and when when Nick Stoller and Judd
and I sat down and started working on
the movie no one ever thought this is a
historic movie it's the first gay this
or the first gay that we didn't even
know at the time right you know we just
said what happened to great comedies
that make people laugh out loud
consistently for an hour and 45 minutes
that also move you and our feel-good
movies you know like that genre of movie
has disappeared you know I grew up with
all these great romantic comedies as did
Nick and as did Judge they're straight
I'm gay but we bonded over our love for
movies like Moonstruck and uh When Harry
Met Sally and working girl and Broadcast
News which is like one of my favorite
movies ever me too absolutely and
they've stopped making those those
movies about straight people forget gay
people they don't even make that kind of
sophisticated really funny Smart Moving
film about straight people anymore
they've never made them about gay people
so in a way Bros while being historic
and very new because it happens to be
about a gay couple it's also a throwback
to those types of romantic comedies
which they simply do not make and when I
watch an audience watch Bros that's the
experience they're having and on top of
it it's also unlike anything a lot of
people have ever seen because of the
lgbtq of it all but they're also just
realizing oh wow it's so fun to go to a
movie theater and be swept away by a
movie like that you know you've gone to
these screenings now and you've seen
your work and you've seen people
laughing at it are you able to because
this is something I when I asked
different guests this over the years
because it's something that kind of
fascinates me
um
connect with that moment when you think
about all you've been through and all
the years where it wasn't happening and
you're out on the street uh yeah
literally out on the street trying to
make it happen and they're trying to put
you into a FedEx envelope to send you to
Bravo yep and now you're having this
moment are you able to connect to it
because it isn't a given that you can
part of being me is that I really care
about doing a good job especially with
this movie like the pressure is on for
me personally it's my first big movie
but then I also have my whole Community
you know waiting to see how I'm gonna
represent them and then I have the
industry waiting to see how it's gonna
do so there was a lot of pressure any
movie's a lot of pressure right
especially in comedy it's really hard to
make a lot of strangers laugh but this
movie had all these other things that
were on my mind too and I but you know
what this was such a special rare
experience this movie and I did think
about all all those generations of lgbtq
folks in Hollywood who did not get this
opportunity who would have just I mean
who would just be shocked to see that
this was happening and the fact that I
was getting it and this whole cast of
openly lgbtq actors that we were getting
this opportunity and you know there was
a moment we were filming me and Luke
McFarland he plays my boyfriend in the
movie and we were filming a scene this
sort of classic New York rom-com walk
and talk on Central Park West and we
were filming it and I thought
this is Tom Hanks and Meg Ryan you know
this is Woody Allen and Diane Keaton
this is all those movies I grew up
watching like all those New York
rom-coms but it's about a two gay guys
and no one has ever had this experience
it's being produced by the same Studio
that makes Jurassic world and Fast and
the Furious and the same guy who made
bridesmaids and all these movies that I
love and I thought I literally told
myself you better [ __ ] pause right
now yeah and look around because this is
special like this is a magical thing and
you get to be a part of it and you need
to take five minutes to stop worrying
about it being good and all the things
you want it to be which is very hard for
me but you need to just live in this
moment because it really it's it's very
unique I'm glad you did that I'm glad
you had that moment and then I screamed
at the crew to get back to work and let
me have my magical moment
what are you eating the moment you get
that profiterole we're not paying for
that slap the moment is for me not you
look you had me because that was a nice
moment but then you were cruel to people
who work for you I'm sorry and that is
my Mantra Oh I thought you were going a
different direction I'm speaking there
we go
no I did I didn't do that I know we know
you didn't do it and I didn't really
ever treat you badly Sona quiet
um please cutter Mike
make sure I I tell people because
um you know we don't even really talk
that much on this podcast we don't uh
it's funny it's not like the Late Night
show where I always end by saying oh and
here's where you can see it's it's not
really about projects so much this uh
I'm definitely want to get the word out
because Bros is in theaters it's uh
coming September 30th and only in
theaters don't be a lazy [ __ ] you gotta
get up off your couch you gotta actually
leave your house and go to a movie
theater to see it but I am telling you
that's what makes it an incredible
experience I think we've all convinced
ourselves I did too especially during
covid that watching a movie at home is
the same or maybe even better I am
telling you I have now sat through all
these screenings of bros at multiplexes
all over the country
it is we have forgotten how much fun it
is to sit in a dark theater with
strangers and Escape our Bleak
anxiety-ridden lives and all the
horrible headlines and just lose
ourselves and laugh for two hours with
hundreds of people in a movie theater oh
I've the times recently that I've gone
back into a movie theater I've been
ecstatic it is
so fun yeah and this movie especially is
a really special one to experience it
really is historic and um you know I
really hope everyone checks it out well
they will I will I'm looking forward to
it September 30th uh which is in just a
couple of days so
um
what did you say don't be a lazy [ __ ] I
think that's the motto here don't be a
lazy [ __ ] all right Conan retired that
lazy ass I'm retired I'm talking to you
I'm not at home eating cookies I want to
be but I'm here getting the word out on
bro I'm working as hard as I ever did
uh I want to buy those Greek Islands
back I had to sell that
um hey uh you know it's so strange
because sometimes I have this
overwhelming impulse and we've talked
about this sooner where I want to tell
someone I'm proud of them and I think
that's weird because if I'm proud of
somebody it usually is reserved for you
know I'm your dad or I was instrumental
at the beginning no I I've I've famously
tried to crush your dreams at every turn
but I really am I'm proud of you you're
you're a very good person I think you're
a really principled Creator and you're
very talented thank you and you're doing
uh something yes it's important but uh
your work is also very good and
um so it's an honor to sit with you
honestly with you and you were all jokes
aside a real early adopter
um and a real early supporter of mine
and I really have always appreciated it
oh thank you it's funny because we make
these jokes and then I can just imagine
people thinking
Conan really tried to have Billy killed
that was such a strange Choice honestly
I could use the headlines so lean in
you don't know what I've been through as
a gay man I couldn't get married I
couldn't have children and then Conan
O'Brien tried to assassinate me
that's the stuff you always had to cut
out of Billy on the streets was ninjas
attacking you yeah which you should have
kept in by the way because that was the
I thought very funny uh really funny bit